Serge
lechimie monsieur le Premier
ministre nous savions que pour Monsieur
Guan la distance entre immigration et
invasion est totalement inexistant et
qu'il peut savemment entretenir la
confusion entre civilisation et régime
politique ce n'est pas un
dérapage c'est une constante
parfaitement volontaire clair c'est un
état d'esprit et c'est presque une
croisade monsieur guant vous déclarez du
fond de votre Abî sans remord et ni
regret que toutes les civilisations ne
se valent pas que certaines seraient
plus avancé voire supérieur non monsieur
guant et non à vous aussi ce n'est pas
du bon sens c'est simplement une injure
qui est faite à l'homme c'est une
négation de la richesse des aventures
humaines c'est un attentat contre le
concert des peuples de culture et de
civilisation aucuniv
l'anage des ténèbres de l'auguste éclat
aucun peuple n'a le monopole de la beuté
de la science du progrès ou de
l'intelligence mon disait chaque homme
porte la forme entière d'une humaine
condition
jouscr mais vous monsieur vous privilégz
l'ombre vous nous ramenez jour après
jour à ces idéologies européen qui on
donnéiss au de concentration au bout du
long Chapel esclavagiste et colonial
monsieur
Guan le régime naz soucieux de
purification une civilisation ch la Barb
dans
laonisation Mission civilisat il
exe c la nostalgie cette épo que vous TZ
de
récupérerangerem AC il existe une autre
je vous en PR cond de Volta de C je vous
en prie ou d'autres encore une France
qui nous invite à la reconnaissance que
chaque
homme
dans Monsieur le Ministre des relation
avec le
[Applaudissements]
Parlement se
calmez demander au ministre répond allez
demander au ministre je vous en prie mes
chers collègues on se
calme monsieur le ministre des Relations
avec le
Parlement qui y a-t-il une
réponse cette intervention
appelle-t-elle une réponse du
gouvernement
elle est vite
demandé
comment la séance est
suspendue